لست متأكدًا مما إذا كنت سأذهب
، ليس لدي أي خطط مباشرة في الوقت الحالي ولكن
دعني
أخبرك أنني منخرط في محاولة
العمل مع كيف يمكننا تحقيق المزيد من
الاستقرار والسلام في الشرق الأوسط
وهناك احتمال
أنني سألتقي بالإسرائيليين
وبعض الدول العربية في ذلك الوقت ،
بما في ذلك أتوقع أن تكون المملكة العربية السعودية
مشمولة في ذلك إذا ذهبت ولكن
ليس لدي خطط مباشرة في الوقت الحالي
في عينيك.
لن أغير وجهة نظري حول
حقوق الإنسان ، لكن كرئيس للولايات المتحدة ، فإن
وظيفتي هي إحلال
السلام إذا كان بإمكاني ذلك ، وهذا ما
سأحاول القيام به يا سيادة الرئيس ، هل ستكون
منفتحًا على الاجتماع مع ولي العهد
محمد بن سلمان ، إذا انتهى بك الأمر
بالذهاب إلى المملكة العربية السعودية ، فانظر ،
فنحن نتقدم على أنفسنا
هنا ، ما أريد أن أفعله هو أن أعمل على
تقليل احتمالية استمرار
هذه الحروب الحمقاء بين
إسرائيل و  الدول العربية وهذا
ما أنا عليه  مركزة